okay hello everyone starting a little
late here
we
were talking about this is talking about
multi-computation and
building
applications of it in wolfram language
and
uh let's see last time
we had finished by talking about
what we were talking a little bit about
functions that manipulate pure functions
and we actually in a different meeting
we're talking about functions that
manipulate held expressions and maybe we
should
hold those thoughts
for that other meeting
we've also been talking in this meeting
again about another
topic that
arguably should be in other meetings
which is about this
concept of uh
well we don't have a great name for it
yet
aware
supplied this thing that
can
pull in
uh
ambient information
uh
when when a function is applied in a
particular environment
now
i think the bigger picture here and
maybe maybe if nick is here he might
have something to say about this
um
is
uh
you know the the
kind of
the the representation of evaluation in
other words what we have mostly
concentrated on in
our language is you have an input
you compute you get an output
the question is to represent the process
of computation how do we symbolicize
the representation of the process of
computation
and trace was an inadequate answer to
that from 1990 or so
and we are now interested in you know
how can we go further
so i don't know if if is nick with us
if if he is maybe he has something to
say about this
well not much either
not really
i just have some ideas about maybe
generalizing token on graphs
how you can make it more
multi-computational
and so on but not really something
concrete okay
i mean i think the issue with trace is
trace is kind of a
uh
gives you a sequential history
i mean the way i view it right now
is
uh you know trace is giving you a
sequential history of a computation
there are these two different aspects of
how you get to the next part of the
computation
one is reevaluation and the other is
recursion through an expression
and
that's sort of one thing
you know
one point about trace is that trace is
clearly giving you only one computation
path
if you had for example pattern matching
and there are multiple
you know matches that could happen
trace is only going to show you the
result of taking one of those matches
and what we ultimately want is a
multi-way graph that represents all
possible such matches
because then we think that we're going
to be able to do
sort of other types of computations
where we're tracking not just the one
match that happened but all possible
matches
but i think what we've got
um
in uh
you know we have this continuing
challenge to
uh on the one hand we can have
something where the states of the system
are well represented
but where there is
redundancy when it comes to looking at
different branches of history
or we can have something like a token
event graph where we've shattered the
states
so that we don't have redundancy across
different branches of history and we're
only showing separately things which are
genuinely different but then it's
unclear how to reconstruct the states
and uh
um
we were talking last time about
jonathan's local multi-way systems
as a
a way to go between those things
but i mean that's kind of the
um
and now
i mean i guess we had also been talking
about um
um
[Music]
uh
the
well okay another thing that had come up
was the question of
of light weight
of okay if we're actually going to
implement multi-computation
um doing lightweight parallelism
uh within
for example within the evaluator and i
think christopher had mentioned some
possible ideas and we're jumping around
different topics here but christopher
had mentioned some possible ideas about
how to actually implement
uh
lightweight parallelism
is there i mean i don't know
i don't i don't really have any ideas i
mean i i have no idea how it would work
and i mean i don't think i
yeah i mean i i i i'm not sure uh i'm
not sure how impossible it is anyway but
yeah
okay
all right well so we have
um and then
okay maybe we should make a list of what
are the related things that we are
trying to work on
okay just to to this is our
our
list of targets so to speak
so
we have
just save this away in the right place
um
you know finally i have been for many
years i've had this naming convention
for files where i start o1 etc and
finally with this multi with this meta
mathematics project i finally hit 100
with the number of uh number of files in
a given topic
um
okay i'm not sure that's a good sign or
whatever okay so let's just make a
little bit of a list of what we're what
we think we're doing so one thing is
um
sort of the generalized trace well okay
one thing
is
situationally aware
um
function application
um and that's
uh another thing is
um
generalized trace
symbolic representation of computation
uh
oh look at this ian is putting something
in the chat
hold on let me just generalize trace
symbolic
okay so another thing we've been talking
about is
which i again i think is not quite so
related is manipulation of held express
meta programming manipulation of held
expressions
um
once we have this okay so then we've got
sort of the
uh
multi-way generalization
of evaluation
which turns into kind of
things like multi-replace
uh
let's see another thing that we have
been starting to talk about was
um manipulation of function
objects
we just started talking about that last
time
and we also talked about uh yeah okay
that's another one manipulation of
patterns
well another one
well then there's also
lazy and infinite data structures
um
lightweight power there's a lot of
topics here
lightweight parallelism
in the evaluator
and
as soon as we have multi-way
generalization of evaluation we've also
got these things about traversal
uh
well i suppose that's even a separate
topic i mean it's it's some
uh
um
symbolic description of traversal orders
yeah that's a topic that even even even
occurs
even without multi-way computation
although it's more poignant in that case
all right so ian
as a piece of code ian can you say what
this code is supposed to do
so this is some
code that jose and i put together of
converting the output of trace into a
tree
ah okay all right okay so let's let's um
you know what i'm going to put this in a
separate notebook here
okay so let's take a look at that so
let's
where would we have a good sample of
trace output
um
is this a sample of trace
where's a good sample of trace do you
have a good sample of trace
you should have a function definition
there
f zero f of one
what do you mean in this other note that
no book yet
okay all right okay
oh okay
what is this
all right this is all in one cell well i
understand what what what is this this
is
x equal one
semicolon x plus plus
okay
maybe try running trace of that for
comparison
or
except copy out that trace
and have that as a separate input
okay so let's take a look here
so x equals one x plus plus and now
what you're saying is and i'm i'm a
little bit confused here because this is
kind of a head
that's because i didn't trace original
goes to true
what does that mean change that to false
you get the default behavior
okay but so let me try doing this
just do nest tree of like percent
there
of that like this
is this helpful
let's try to understand this first of
all
okay x equals one x plus plus
okay x equals one gives one
okay
x plus plus evaluates x
what the heck is that one doing there
is that the return value i see x gives
one and then this is the return value
there okay let's let's do a more serious
i mean let's do something okay so let me
let me just
your notebook on the right you have a
function definition
at the bottom
maybe you could try just like a
fibonacci like a little recursive yeah
okay but but so this is now a
compound expression so that's
um
okay
there fibonacci good
let's get rid of my x definition here
before it blows everything up
okay there's fibonacci
and now
what i want to do i wanted to trace the
four
so let's go ahead and say so do i need
all this apparatus here infinity trace
data what do i need here just change the
inside of the trace
okay
maybe set the aspect ratio to be really
wide
i'm gonna just uh so the exercise here
is to distinguish the evaluation
vertically
from the
um
follow other elements
horizontally
or perhaps i'm saying it in reverse i i
always have to think
so one i would have expected that you'd
have the f of three at the top and then
a child of that would be the f of three
minus one plus f of three minus two and
then that would have the children
uh but i would have expected two three
minus two you know et cetera
what just trace gives
well i mean trace may be just completely
wrongly designed
just just well he does something
systematic
i understand
so here f 3 is actually a sibling
we've made it a parent in the tree
right but it should be this
everything that comes from this
is causally dependent
look if if we think about what
needs to have existed in order for
something here to be done
i don't even understand what is that
three one two what the heck is that
what is that why is there a list why is
there anything like a list anywhere here
i don't understand that that is that is
representing a sub evaluation
what kind of a sub evaluation oh you
mean you mean three minus one but i
don't understand i thought the
evaluation went down the page here
okay look you've got two kinds of edges
this is what we keep on talking about
you've got an evaluation edge two minus
one is one
and here you've got a recursion edge i'm
looking at the first elements of the
list and the second elements of the list
is that correct and what the heck is
this f of one doing here
what is that
no this is the wrong way around i mean
trace is doing something completely
crazy
in my view and maybe it makes more sense
if you did trace original goes to true
okay that does potentially make more
sense
okay let's take a look at this creature
all right f of three
now
it's child nodes
oh i don't understand this at all so the
standard evaluation procedure for an
expression is to evaluate the head i
know evaluate the arguments that's what
you see so there's a child for f
there's a child with three
but then the child for f of three
evaluates and becomes f of three minus
one plus f of three minus yeah but why
doesn't that is why isn't that an arc
going you know an edge going down
because it's not evaluating a sub
expression
f of three gets replaced with f of three
minus one plus f of three minus two i
know but edge is going down when you're
evaluating sub-expressions
what
why is f of two minus one a
sub-expression of f of three minus one
no this doesn't make any sense look the
sub expressions of f of 3 are f and 3.
right and those are fine i mean so we
really want two kinds of edges here
we want
a sub expression evaluation edge
and we want
a
um
a
an evaluation edge we want a a sub
expression recursion edge
okay claim
we need a sub-expression recursion edge
and we need
a replacement substitution
reevaluation edge
okay right so this is just showing this
the recursion edges and the replacement
substitution reevaluation edges are not
shown those are just siblings yeah which
is completely utterly confusing
okay so now my claim would be
that um
in the simplest case
the replacement edge
um just is just
of the form you know
initial
exper
you know arrow
final exper
but the full representation
is more like a token event graph
uh
in which there's another incoming
there's
uh another incoming edge
that
brings in the rule
for doing the uh
reevaluate for doing the replacement
does this make any sense
so in other words if we see here f of
three goes to f of two plus f of one
that is
a mere you know that will be showed up
as initial expression evaluation edge
final expression
but in reality what we should be seeing
there
is something of the form you know
rule
plus initial edge
initial
goes to final
does that make sense and and now that's
the you know the
um
but
uh and in the multi-computation case
it's more like rule plus initial goes to
final one final two final three
is this making sense to people
so i claim that's the graph we want
as we want
we want
so i understand i think
that that you want some kind of
visualization that would show a
relationship between the f of three and
the f of three minus one plus f of three
minus two that includes the rule like
you're saying there no but i'm not sure
what the graph is that you're wanting
like is it
is it adding additional edges to the
graph above or is it some different
structure i don't know because i think
some pieces of the graph above i
actually do not understand
okay i don't understand why there's an f
of three here when there's already an f
of three and why that's a sibling node
it just doesn't make any sense to me
just doesn't make any sense that this
look what i would expect is
there is okay so let's see if we can
draw the graph
that corresponds to the map
okay
the
the um what i would call the map all
graph okay
okay so what does that mean that means a
graph where we have an expression let's
say we've got
you know f of g of x of g
of y of comma g of
x comma whatever i don't know we put add
in some other things just for fun
here f of
you know g of y whatever okay so this
thing
that thing
has
okay so let's try and make the
expression tree of that
i know which expression should we want
here
what the heck oh for god's freaking sake
this is what we get for doing this i
hate doing that
okay
but what's the most appropriate
expression tree to represent the
operation of maple
do you understand what i'm asking
you've got a version of expression tree
that will show me
in its in its uh
nodes will show me the successive
expressions that are fed to map all
do you understand what i'm saying
ian uh do comma sub expressions
okay so because what i want to see
is if i take this thing
why isn't this working okay
if i take that thing and i say
map all
of echo
comma this
okay boom there i get that
yep right
okay so now what i want to see
is expression tree
of that
comma what sub-expressions yep
okay i know what that those two arcs are
doing there but
oh i see there we go okay so now let's
look at this
compared to this
i don't understand this at all
so in the recursion
that would be the recursion of where
slash dot
where the evaluator visits
what the the evaluator makes a
depth-first traversal of this tree is
that correct
minus attributes i guess
so okay
all right so we can see that presumably
how can we see that i'm surprised map
all doesn't show
oh i see maple okay what i really need
to do is heads arrow true either that or
the sub expression should have a heads
is there a heads false option for the
sub expressions thing there there will
be for now replace sub expressions with
the string arguments
okay so now let me go back
up here
and replace that
okay
so
the claim would be
that this thing here
is the same as the map all results if we
do a depth first traversal of this tree
we will get the same sequence as that
sequence there
yep
i believe that to be correct
yeah if you did a tree map of echo
over the expression tree you'll get the
same okay all right so let's just
understand here so if we do a map all
here
with heads goes to true
we'll get that
and that will correspond to this okay f
g yup okay fine
okay so and that's what we get
with
when we do a tree
on this tree here
what you're saying is if we take that
tree
and we do
a tree map
of echo
on that tree
we will get
the same thing
right now were we to do a tree map with
a different traversal order
so let's just to understand what we're
doing here
we would say traversal order
is it tree traversal order traversal
order
okay so now let's say i is there a
breadth first option
yep
okay i don't understand oh i see we got
back out the same expression here
but here
breadth first
beautiful beautiful
okay i understand how that works
okay so this
this kind of tree
represents our
essentially
expression traversal
i mean it's a little confusing
that in okay so
expression traversal
is the depth first version of this tree
expression evaluation
in a sense we can connect any one of
these things
to another so for example let me just do
a trivial case here
so if i do
the same thing if i do an expression
tree of arguments
oh what is happening with this
multi-click
why is multi-click not working who knows
okay so let's just do this let's say
i've got
a fibonacci and i've gone two levels and
i'm going to call it
uh plus lowercase plus just because i
don't want it to but actually i could do
an inactive plus wouldn't i if i just
say f of
you know five minus one
plus f of
uh
let's say four minus one
no sorry five minus two
and then that whole thing plus
let's say
um f of
six minus one
plus f of six minus two
say and then i want to inactivate this
no just wrap the whole thing in
unevaluated
couldn't i say
inactivated could not be happy with the
answer okay so can you fix that and have
a version that's going to be fixed you
just don't want to see an expression
tree with lots of i know that i know
that i want you to make an expression
tree which ignores the inactive things
okay
okay okay beautiful so now
let's take a look at what this is okay
so this is
the the recursion
this is the pure
expression traversal recursion of that
object
okay
oh but it evaluated
what the heck
wait a minute
i don't understand i mean
the tree doesn't hold the data so well
so maybe held arguments instead
the string held arguments
okay
okay so this is now
pure
expression traversal recursion
okay but now what's going to happen is
then there is the evaluation recursion
am i making sense
so
from this tree
we now have
another edge
that comes from
let's say f of 5-1
that other edge
is applying the rule
to get to f of
you know five minus what well no
actually
so so in order to to have done this
first
the symbol plus would have evaluated
and then the two branches you see are
the result of evaluating the arguments
and then you need a representation for
applying plus to its arguments
yeah but the thing i'm trying to say yes
that's what i'm that's what i'm talking
about we've now evaluated the sub
expressions according to the standard
evaluation procedure now we want to
apply a rule to what we exactly exactly
so so the question now is let's just
take five minus one here okay let's take
a much more trivial case
okay let's take
uh
2 plus
3
okay
okay we've got this
that is a representation of
sub-expression recursion
okay now
we need something else here we need
another edge
coming out of this
and what's very confusing here
is that
you know where is time in this whole
thing
i mean this is where
arguably
is there a notion of reverse graph here
or reverse tree no how do we get this
into
uh
oh for goodness sake it doesn't label
those
well okay so let's say we have this
what is going on with multi-clicking
here
somehow multi-clicking is broken
can somebody i don't know what version
i'm running let's see what version i'm
running here
that's really odd
i'm worth checking into
yep i can look into that
okay
i don't know why it doesn't draw it
upside down but
what what happened here
oh i see because it's got tree
those are tree labels here right
so if i say vertex labels arrow
v underscore colon
greater than first
will i get the right thing
do you understand what i'm doing here
did i get the graph the wrong way around
again no i didn't reverse
i know that i know that i know that but
so what's happening here is
two and three
together make two plus three
which then
takes a rule from the outside world and
makes five
does that make sense
yep
and but
but here
one of these edge you know these edges
we can say call them you know structural
edges or something okay so so one thing
we could say is
there are there would there would really
be another edge from the symbol plus
going into that yes there would be so so
can we do that with heads goes to true
somewhere here do you held sub
expressions
instead of held arguments
by the way not to throw a complete
wrench but uh i mean what how is it
supposed to
deal with things like up values
that is a wrench
presumably that's
we have to display the rule a certain
way
no you know what that is quite a down
value or applied an up value or
yes but you're going to argue that it's
just the same as down values because
it's just a replacement yes but the
point is no no but no i'm not going to
actually argue that completely i'm going
to say that
that that's actually an interesting idea
because it's essentially an edge that
connects so the evaluation edge
would normally just say
bring in
okay the evaluation edge okay here's a
claim okay wait a minute there are
structural edges
representing
how expressions are built up
are structurally built
okay then
we've also got separately
there are evaluation edges
representing actual transformations
okay so what's the input to the actual
transformation my argument would be here
the input is plus
because that's the thing that has the
down code
whereas if there was an up value the
input will be from further further down
in the tree i thought the input was plus
of two comma three no it is i would have
thought it'd be the whole expression no
i know that but the whole point is okay
look the whole point is like in a token
event graph there are two inputs here
okay so let's look at how this works for
um
uh nick can you can you give us an
example of something where we're
applying a rule in a token event graph
and we see a substitution happening
substitution where it's like just a
binary it's already substitution
no i i know but what i'm trying to see
is what i'm trying to see is in a token
event graph right
we're going to make
help how to do this i'm trying to see
something
where i'm going to have an edge i'm
going to have something that says
you know f x blank
goes to
uh whatever x plus one
and then i'm gonna have
that's
one token
and then i'm gonna have f of seven
and then that's another token
and those two things come together in an
event
and the event consists of applying this
rule
to this object
right and then the result is f of h or
is it eight or whatever right how do we
make that again in a in a token event
graph
oh you can make a specific pattern
for example your rule would be
left hand side of your rule would be
like a list
when the first element ex accepts
expects a rule
and the second element would expect some
just arbitrary expression
right but that's exactly what's
happening when we use a substitution
lemma
or don't you have code that does that
the text you can use the token graph you
just make a rule that has left-hand side
like two elements in the list
right can you can you just show me the
code i i'm not understanding this but
the point that i'm making is
these structural edges
i claim
make a tree here
although
even that if they're common sub
expressions there would be a dag
making sense
but they i mean you know this is
mostly a tree
except for common sub expressions
or eg
x
which is a shared
thing
in in general like the two and the three
would have been
things that came from the evaluation of
some other
expression
yeah right
so i don't know that the arrow is really
pointing from a sub-expression into it
so much as it's pointing from
an evaluation
like the nodes are no no there's two
different things here guys
and jonathan sent a giant piece of code
here which we're about to try to
understand
jonathan can you send an example of how
this is used oh very good
um
okay let's take a look at this
okay hold on but i'm trying to explain
this again okay
and this is something which in fact
interestingly came up just yesterday in
connection with the compiler
in the compiler an expression is a
bundle of two things an expressionist
structure a struct
and it is also an evaluation semantics
you know we have both of those things
bundled together you know the evaluator
and things we do with expressions both
any expression is automatically acted
upon by the evaluator that is our
standard model for our language
but we can imagine an expression devoid
of evaluation
the thing we were calling expert struct
yesterday
and then we separately can add an
evaluation so what i'm saying here is
the structural edges business
is the story of an expression devoid of
evaluation
that makes sense it's it's still
it's saying how is the expression put
together
but that's independent of how it's how
evaluation happens and that reflects
the evaluator
look the evaluator when it all it's
doing is echoing
the evaluator is just visiting parts of
the expression doesn't happen to do
anything with those parts of the
expression it just returns them
unevaluated
but if it were to do something
there will be two actions that it takes
in the you know
the the
the operation of the evaluator comes
first from
its push to recurse and second from its
push to replace
right
i mean so a way to say this is
the evaluator and of course when it's
hold all then it's first by its push to
replace and then by its push to recover
right
but so it has two fundamental
uh operations
recurse
in structure
and
replace a structure
with replace taking precedence because
of
things like attributes
well yes that's right but i mean in in
right and then the attributes
you're going to change how you recurse
or not recurse at all
yes okay so nick has a
thing here let me take a look at next
and then we'll look at jonathan's
um
oh my god
so complicated already
okay let's try to understand this
okay f of three
oh i see
f of three
uses the rule this rule
to produce f of two and f of one
is this making sense to people
these are evaluation edges
yes
the f of three and the rule node are
those supposed to be graphically
distinct
things or are they yeah those are that
that rule node is a is a different color
for now
i mean in the end it's just an
expression right but but for now we're
thinking of that as
that is a rule to be applied if that was
down code
code you know internal code in the
system there will be no visible node
here it would merely be
a magic pixie dust
that
uh you know
is used in this
actual evaluation you know event
to produce f of two
so the so
do the yellow disks always have
exactly two parents an expression and a
rule
yes in this case yes
they're saying an expression and then
what you do and then a rule that
describes what to do to that expression
and it has two children because
no it doesn't necessarily have two
children in this one i'm saying has two
children because of the right-hand side
of this rule
yeah i mean yes because because nick is
representing lists
as a multi-computational kind of thing i
mean i would say that normally this
would have one child and that's where we
get this rep you know relationship
between the recursion the pure
structural recursion right normally this
would have one child
yeah the one child would be like f of n
minus one plus f of n minus two exactly
so i mean i'm sure we can just change
nick's code here can we nick and just
change that to
f of n minus one plus f of n minus two
here
and then it probably won't do anything
very exciting
it'll just show
okay it's got some weirdness in there
but but basically that's showing this
phenomenon right
yep that's just showing f of three goes
to this
um
and then what we
what's the other arrow going from the
disc back to the rule
i don't
trying to reproduce it it's also an
output
because the token graph by default
removes the token that comes into event
and in order to keep it alive so to
speak you have to
reproduce it
right so what nick is saying is
the the if this rule
is an external force acting on the
system
then it has to be gosh that's an
interesting way to think about it it's
like an external potential in physics
um
that uh
you know outside of the system and
always there
but nick is saying if you want to go
microscopic with it then it has to be
the case that the event
you know gives you back that rule
otherwise the rule would've disappeared
otherwise we've erased the code
basically so there's two kinds of
incoming edges and two in kinds of
outgoing edges
to and from expressions into and from
rules
well look
okay like in this meta mathematics
project we've been doing those two rules
and expressions merge in the end but at
this level we're treating them as
distinct
and certainly with respect to our
internal code that's a rule that you
cannot look inside so to speak
right that's a rule that's an atomic
rule so to speak atomic conserved rule
right
eg you know
rules that
persistently that persists
are like
external potentials in physics
and uh eg
you know down code persists
and it doesn't need to be i mean again
in nick's description of a token event
graph
one is going full microscopic and one's
having to say
let us actually say that that rule is
preserved by explicitly having it come
out
okay should we look at jonathan's
thing here
okay
okay what is this doing
jonathan well i i was asking a question
um which is is this is what we want a
globalized version of this
i don't know can you define terms
sure i mean obviously this is just the
multi-way this is the multi-way state
evaluation semantics for ff5 given the
fibonacci rule given except that it's
been doing it's done something here it's
done essentially a breadth-first
compression right but this is not
this is not in fact
the evaluation semantics of our current
evaluator
right the evaluation semantics of our
current evaluator is a pure tree with no
sub-expression combination
well so each each sub-expression is
being simplified only the only to the
extent that the front-end automatically
simplifies it
i i understand but i'm saying i don't
understand the edge from f of 3 plus f 4
to f of 4 plus 3.
so f 3 is being evaluated to three
yes do we see that
but normally okay can ian can your code
generate the standard fibonacci
evaluation tree
yeah um okay how do we do that we do do
that with with trace with a
where is it
we did it already didn't we i mean if if
you want the thing with no sub
expression re-evaluation you just run
the multi-operator system like that okay
let's try it
sorry that's for f of 4 but you can
change it to f 5
for consistency
does anybody have any idea why
this
why the graph drawing system puts that
node there i think avery if you could
just point this out to charles i just
don't think it makes any sense i don't
know why it does that
yeah but i can do that like that
okay in any case
uh i think this is still being smart to
an extent yeah it is a little bit but
the only in the rendering um
yeah it's just it's getting rid of
parentheses and the rendering i think
uh but the the actual underlying
evolution evaluation is as dumb as it
possibly can be no wait wait a second
though wait a second wait a second wait
a second wait a second this is something
where
every node
will have the same value we'll have
value the value of f four
but that's not the same way round
oh gosh i'm confused here
that's not the same way round as what we
would get you're like doing the
replacements in in place
right
yes in this case showing how it evolves
right so so normally what i would expect
is
in
let's see can we get next system to
actually
show us
okay we've got f of 3
no it's not going to show us this either
but but in principle okay if we if we
had another node here we had another
event
that was the down code for plus
then next system in fact why don't we
just do that why don't we have something
here that can we do that what can we
turn this into here we can go let's try
doing this
okay instead of this let's call it p
of that comma that
let's have another rule
wait a second why
nick can we have another rule here
that is also applied that says p of
okay so we have a list of
just a list of tokens you just had
another rule
and you have p of a blank b blank
uh
arrow a plus b
you want to say blank integer
maybe i do
just to simulate that the plus wouldn't
be doing anything until the things had
evaluated
can you remove the splice
i don't need it
where even is the splice i don't even
see it where is it
oh there yeah
okay do i want to
let's see that two probably wants to
increase
oh my god these things are hard to
understand
ok so
what's happening here is f of three
combined with that rule turns into p of
f of two f of one
okay i think we want the end conditions
as well don't we in order to make this
sensible
do we want so let's give the end
condition
f of one arrow one
f of two arrow one
oh my gosh
at this creature
it would work it would look better if
you like remove
those extra cycles that's what we do for
the mathematics
okay how do we do that but i don't i
have like a separate function for that
can you send it to me
yeah
okay the thing that's bothering me is
that i'm not seeing
a five or something come out here
i don't understand why i wouldn't be
seeing that
why am i not seeing the application of
the p rule
actually giving
results
because it's not an integer right the
only
p expression you have with f's inside
but i have to hit the base case
to get an integer is what you're saying
yeah it's not drilling down the
expression it's just otherwise
but wait a second but
i see so this doesn't have the recursion
part of the evaluator is what you're
saying
this is only whole expression and that's
perhaps where jonathan's glocalization
comment comes from
is that right jonathan
this is what i'm asking right
i want to make sure that i understand
the problem
yeah i think that is a statement of the
problem that is that is we have
in the end here
okay
we've got a multi-way graph which in the
case of our particular evaluator
you know resolves to a single way graph
that represents the evaluation
but then the question is
uh
what we want to do
is to represent
not just
because
the operations are not just being done
on whole states
they're being done on these sub sub
trees
yes that that's i mean that's
essentially what we're talking about is
that is this interplay between
whole state reevaluation
and
you know recursion into an expression
which i think is the same as the
glocalization problem
is it
well i i think so too that's what i was
confirming i mean actually if you let me
share screen for a second i can show you
the uh the opera the full operator for i
showed the combinator version the full
operator form of global multi-way system
is not yet in the function repository
although the code is complete but that
would be the sort of this would be the
global version of that evaluation
okay let's take a look at this puppy
f of four
right so we start with f of four
we evaluate to plus
f of two f of three so we've got two
versions of the f token one version of
the plus token one version of the two
token and one version of the three token
but those have been deduplicated so the
f token
this is like our symbol table it's at
least at this
uh
time this evaluation slice it's been
deduplicated there's only one f here
even though but there are two edges to
it crucially right yeah right
this event is generating two f's how do
we know that f how do we know that the
expression being represented there is
plus of f of two etcetera etcetera
etcetera rather than just a bucket with
a plus two f's a two and a three
right right exactly so each of these
edges is tagged with essentially part
specifications of where these things lie
in the expression tree
yes
um i still need to figure out a better
so obviously for the pure you know
graphic writing case or something that
doesn't matter because the way that you
set up you know the the way the order
hyper it there's no kind of um hierarchy
in the way that you order hyper edges
but for general expressions there
obviously is so i still need to figure
out a nice way to visualize how that
edge tagging information is actually
stored well you are you are flowing
right back into the same question that
we keep on having which is these two
forms of of essentially graph
you are representing an evaluation graph
here
and as you say you have to superimpose
on that
this expression graph
expression structure graph
and
also
you know in our usual physics project
hyperedges thing all we've got is uh is
flat
ordered lists effectively of of
of of atoms but in this case we have
more structure to that you know we have
whole expressions
um rather than just lists of atoms
right and so yes
my initial thought although this might
end up being completely incomprehensible
is that so right now we have two
versions of edges right we have the we
have the causal edges between the
rewrites and we have the evolution edges
between the tokens
my initial idea was to it was to
superimpose a third kind of edge that
showed essentially the the parent child
relationships between elements of the
expression tree
yeah i agree
yeah i mean i think that's the thing to
try doing and and that's that was what i
was asking ian for before that is ian
has gone from uh you know and he
probably use ian's technology for this
ian has the tree basically as a tree
right that represents um
and what i was asking ian to do was to
add the edges that you have here
that represent evaluation so this is
actually touching on one of the key
differences between a tree
and a graph which is in graph you it's
kind of like just a bucket of vertices
and edges
there may be some inherent ordering but
in tree
like every there's like these siblings
you are ordered
amongst your siblings there's a definite
first sibling second sibling third
sibling
and that's always preserved one and the
other thing is that in tree you can have
you think you don't think of them as
things with names
you think of them as things that can
have a data in them and so it's natural
to have multiple places that have the
same data
right as opposed to your graph you're
accomplishing this by having under here
you have vertices
like i see two f's here but really you
have two vertices with some names i
don't know and you're using a vertex
label to make it show as an f
right right but where's tree it's like
there's an f there
but my question is if we so if we take
this this example here
um if we just superimposed say so four
additional directed edges perhaps in a
different color that had so two edges
between plus and f and then one edge
between f and two and another edge
between f and three
it's not enough it's not enough i think
for the point that i mean the point that
ian is making is
uh
you need more information you need in
this particular case plus happens to be
commutative
you're you're using vertex labels
to have sort of like a payload at each
node like tree does and you're you and
you're tagging the edges with part
numbers so that you have ordering
like tree does
right right that's my point is like
graph
you're accomplishing with vertex labels
and edge labels
what the graph data structure doesn't
actually store no i i completely agree
that's all
right that's all the money
yeah i think i think we're in agreement
there the only point that i'm making is
that th the same issue you have with
with pure edges essentially assuming
for instance in this case that plus is
commutative is the same as the issue you
have with representing it as a pure tree
and ian as you say the way you get
around that in both cases is by having
additional
information tagged onto the edges that
tells you things about ordering and
right and it just so happens that a tree
bites right but a tree is just a nested
thing
whereas a graph does not there's just
explicitly a data in the expression at
that location and then there's
explicitly a list of trees in the
expression at that location okay so what
we're learning here
is that
in a sense there is a i don't know what
it is called i mean that that you could
imagine a data structure that is a
combination of a tree in a graph
where well i guess it's it's like ports
in graphs maybe roger has something to
say about this i mean that this is this
is like numbered ports
in a graph is it not i mean a tree
could be thought of as saying every node
has a collection of numbered ports
coming out of it as opposed to a graph
where all of the where it's just a set
of
edges coming out
rather than an ordered list of edges
coming out
many comments
does roger have any thoughts on that
anybody else
yeah
that ordering
every position i mean you could just use
the pure tree is just a bunch of
position it's a bag of positions
yeah
and
everything else is in addition
but the positions is the only thing
that's needed
no i know but the question is from a
graph what is the combination data
structure
that is both has the features of a tree
and the features of a graph
and i'm claiming it's a graph with
numbered ports
it depends i mean you defined a
particular type of graph the gra you
know a particular type of tree that tree
that's an ordered tree what other kind
of tree is there
a tree is one
where um every node has a single
ancestor
right this is the thing that that
slightly confused me right is that that
the in a sense the tree for plus one
comma two is isomorphics of the tree
plus two comma one
as as a pure tree it's only they're only
distinct if they're ordered trees yeah
i'm drawing a distinction between the
wolf from language tree and a tree graph
right right exactly yeah
and the diff and the things that you
need for tree graphs are essentially
payloads at the vertices which you can
already do
with vertex label or just any annotation
you want vertex weight whatever
and then you want
ordering
of the children
okay look i think we've defined here
you know what it is we need that is
we're trying to have something which is
both a representation of the structural
tree and a representation of the
evaluation process
and in you know we've got different
angles on getting to this
i think the one thing so there's three
kinds of
oh my gosh there's so many different
kinds of edges and so on here i mean all
the complication is because you're gonna
overlay them
as an animation i don't think it is that
complicated
ha ha ha
interesting claim roger no because
you're trying to basically freeze you
know trying to show
like an evaluation graph
yeah you're trying to show the dynamics
in a static way
yes i don't think it's i don't think i
mean we can try it but i don't think it
is i mean what imagine our evaluator
and imagine that you see an expression
and as an animation we could do this
with trace actually as an animation you
see different pieces of um uh if you
want to unshare jonathan i can um of
course but also you you had it in some
other thing i saw
like the nodes could be expressions
you know or trees
but they're not here in all the things
that we've seen today they're sort of
splattered out into pieces
that's correct
that's correct that's right because the
the as soon as you in order to
understand evaluation or recursion
through an expression you have to go
below the whole expression level
but okay but so another thing we could
try to do is an animation of evaluation
eg using trace
right and so what we would see there is
presumably we would see an expression
and we would see things changing
flashing you know that we'd see them
changing i don't know how we arranged to
not have the thing jump around because
of the changing you know let's say we're
doing full form okay we do animation
evaluation eg in full form
is that what you have in mind roger
yeah i mean or or in tree form yeah
actually form
okay
i think it'd be interesting to make that
animation i think it will be quite hard
to understand
but we can certainly make that animation
i think it's a good idea
now i mean like like switzerland
go ahead can we it's kind of like
stepping through an evaluation you can
see things expanding out contracting
doesn't that
well right but there are many different
reference frames in which you can do
that and that's sort of an interesting
thing to realize in for example
fibonacci there's depth first you know
evaluation there's breadth first
evaluation you will see different things
happening like in depth first evaluation
you'll always see just one piece of the
tree lighting up at any given time
whereas in breath first you might see
multiple pieces
but actually not breath first that would
be generational evolution in that
physics project terminology sorry jose
please
i was going to suggest that after this
discussion we go back to the original
three of the trays with the trace
original and we tried to read it again
at the very top of your of your notebook
yes this one
that one there
um
this one you have the larger one this
one for example
yes
so this with trace original two do you
have one yes the next one the next one
yeah
the next one yeah so let's try to read
these so we start with f of three and so
we will say we have we have to evaluate
the head f the head the the argument
three
they don't do anything so we have f of 3
again so i'm reading horizontally
now we have the rule that converts f of
3 into f which you can do when they
order trees
yes yes exactly so so this is what we
are trying to do to distinguish the
vertical direction from the horizontal
direction so i'm trying to read the
order in which this is happening
so we say f of three
is converted into f of three minus one
plus f of three minus two
and and what jonathan was showing was a
nice representation of that step right
right
so now we say we have an expression of
head plus the first argument is f of
three minus one by the way we can
evaluate f of three minus one so we go
down
so we have f and its argument is three
minus one we can evaluate three minus
one it's an expression of head plus
three and minus one they don't do
anything so we get back three minus one
and again the internal rule that
evaluates that to two
we go up we have f of two
and then f of two evaluates into f of
two minus one plus f of two minus two
yeah i'm next okay i'd admit i'm warming
to this picture although it would help
me a lot to have some edges that join
you know these are there's an evaluation
edge here
exactly the the horizon there are
several things in the horizontal steps
and i think that's a confusing point
well maybe we should put those in maybe
we should just have a representation of
this in which we annotate the horizontal
steps here
i mean i think that um
that will be useful maybe we could do
that
make that picture and then then it could
be the case
well do you cont claim that that
contains
okay this my claim is that trace
with trace original true contains
everything it's just hard to read
i understand i understand so so let's
try and annotate this by changing edges
and by adding some some extra
annotational edges
okay so so this let's take this case
here
okay so this case here these are
recursion elements
right these are these are this the
evaluator is going to this to this you
open the plot that jonathan was showing
side by side with this oh if jonathan
sends it to me because it was on his
screen oh sure yep give me one sec
um
i should wrap this meeting up
unfortunately but but we're making
progress here guys
it's complicated
this is the you know 40 years later
we're unbundling evaluation and and uh
expression structure
are you sending this by mail or some
other way
i'm just about to email it to you you
mean you're gonna have to buy it
separately
no we're going to be able no but the
point is roger that you're going to be
able to run the evaluator multiple times
on different cpu you know on different
threads and things if we can understand
how to do this
we can you know that helps in in uh
in saying i'm going to get four
evaluators all at the same time
okay
all right
f of four
is this helping so these yellow events
are what's missing between all of the
like
siblings in the trace tree
okay
because you don't see what rule is being
applied and how yeah i understand i
understand and this question of where
the rule comes from is yet a different
level which we also have to deal with
and that's what nick's token event graph
is showing is where the rule comes from
but that may be another level of
you know complexity beyond this where we
assume for now that every rule is just
you know
ab initio down code from the
uh you know
from the you know already there type
thing
um
all right i do believe we're making
progress right a couple of comments here
from richard let's see
um
yeah commenting on the use of
non-deterministic rewriting
yes i agree
um
okay this is richard commenting on
uh someone's work introducing
correspondence in program optimization
and proof to proof transformation
yes that i mean in a sense and maybe
roger can speak to this i mean in
in
you know even from the 90s and 80s
all these things for doing parallelism
and you know
optimizing loops and unrolling them and
do that and the other i mean people had
lots of program to program
transformations
and which i guess
in the modern view of proofs and
programs being the same thing which they
obviously are
um
you know those techniques presumably
read on proofs as well as they read on
programs
is that a fair
i mean is that a useful comment or is
that anybody want to comment on that in
other words the techniques that people
have for program transformation should
also be proof transformation techniques
and vice versa right
that's correct yes
they know they haven't been
necessarily packaged that way but yes
but so i want to i would be curious to
answer i mean i know jonathan has been
thinking about proof to proof
transformations does anybody have any
idea whether the traditional i mean i
don't know what the good optimizations
are i don't know various kinds of loop
optimizations and so on um
um
the families so so loop is one that i
happen to know more about
and
so you can think of of of nested loops
pretty much like nested sums or
something like that
and
it turns out that a lot of these
transformations
are things that people learn and give
names to
like loop unrolling
or loop reversals or loop
transpositions
um
these these have names in high
performance programming
but they all sort of special k all of
those happen to be unimodular
transformations like a change of
variables
basically so like for example loop
transposition i would imagine if you've
got variables i and j and j doesn't
depend on the j loop doesn't depend on i
but you keep on reevaluating the j loop
over and over again that would be an
example of something yeah it would be
example sometimes you want to do
transposition of of loops to get a
better stride for memory access because
that's just such a crucial thing
to get decent performance
so if you
so you access things that are nearby
each other in memory so i'm curious and
in
proof optimization is there any analog
of loop transformations
um
wait a minute
nick has sent something through here
uh
should i run this
yeah this
that looks fun
my god what the heck is this
okay f of three
makes use of
why does it use that rule so many times
well it uses it at each step because it
can
okay but f three fundamentally using
that rule is transformed f of 1 plus f
of 2.
and f of 2
what is that is that a different kind of
edge
this kind of a sub case edge
wouldn't it have to use that rule again
the general rule the fibonacci rule up
there
well it will on f of 2.
it's going to that's just applying that
other rule the head of args
yeah just to list head args oh there it
goes oh i see i see i see what's
happening i see head of args goes to
list
hedogs i see so that's basically a
representation sort of formal
representation of the sequentiality of
the evaluator
yeah can you add this additional option
it will make things a little bit easier
also notice you can miss the base cases
something is wrong with multi-clicking
i'm going crazy here i rely on
multi-clicking
okay
f of three uses that rule to make f of
one plus f of
two then it uses this rule to shatter
that into f of 2
and
that rule shatters it into f of 2 and f
of 1
right
and plus
oh yeah there's plus down there
hanging out
okay
now
and that rule is also used on f
3 to shatter that into 3 and an f which
doesn't do anything
and then
here
okay
well so this is this is what we're
looking for i mean this is yeah this is
but it's interesting that you have so in
a sense what we probably should be doing
and what would make this clear is if we
had two kinds of events two colors of
events one is the rule application event
and the other is essentially the meta
rule of the evaluator that is go head
followed by args
would would that be
how does it reassemble given the head of
args how does it reassemble that
or does it not need to be this isn't
representing
the evaluation
though right this is like
applying all possible rewrites
you mean is there an answer here like
this is not like the trace
well your claim is there is no
single version of history or whatever
is this is this a multi-history thing
well we'll look at like you can get this
down to these cases where you have f of
minus one
that's true the one way of rewriting it
you end up in the base cases but a
different way you don't
right
do i have the nerve to do this
okay so is the answer ever showing up
here
what is that for four anyway
one one two three five
three
shoot i can't i can't see if i
um
one one
am i going crazy two three
really i have to get five
f six the the first place where i would
see an unexpected number is f six
is that true
well i actually see a number that is a
combination of multiple things
and this is probably going to get
totally crazy
not so crazy
okay is there an eight anywhere in this
picture
because that would be a signal of
evaluation actually having happened
i believe there is no eight here i
believe that's because there's no
additional rule here that goes from the
shattered
subparts of the expression
to the uh you know there needs to be
another rule i think that
what the heck does it do
you have to have a rule that
reassembles the expression to be like
given some head and arms
and a separate head and arc somewhere
floating around
not evaluated already so you so that
they can use them in order to reassemble
it
right
i think that's right
all right we better wrap up for now we
are making great progress guys i mean
and what's also exciting is that a lot
of these graphs you know we'll have a
single way version and then we will
immediately be able to make the jump to
multi-way
and then we can start talking about
traversal orders and you know what count
because traversal order is ultimately
going to i mean something like fibonacci
we have confluence and we're going to
get the same answer independent of
traversal order
but in many cases we won't
and particularly when the computations
are infinite it's going to be extremely
non-trivial what the traversal orders
end up being
well i'm excited i don't know i i hope
other people are finding this some
uh
uh
i mean people are still working on
gaussian elimination just like a whole
industry working on gaussian elimination
in its multiple ways in which it can be
computed
which are essentially evaluation orders
yeah
yeah well okay so i'd love to know roger
if you ever pointed to that literature
one thing that we're trying to do here
which you know ian has done a version of
is the taxonomy of tree traversal orders
right and so if there is a taxonomy of
what amount to traversal orders in the
gaussian elimination literature that
would be interesting to see
well they're usually called left looking
right looking up looking etc frontal
multi-frontal
supernova
great let's look these up those sound
like left most innermost
they're all the whole literature is
graph based when you get to it
no but i understand but i mean this is
where substantial part of graph theory
got developed
but there are names for these things in
um
you know in function evaluation in you
know recursive evaluation like left most
innermost and what you're saying which
is interesting is that there's a
correspondence of that
in these in these numerical analysis
schemes
cool well ultimately everything's
already been invented many times the
only question is but people understand
what it all means
and that's yeah that's i mean that would
be that would be interesting roger would
it be would we be able to use that if we
had a parameterization would we be able
to actually use that in gaussian
elimination
i
think i mean what people are doing is
that they're trying to adapt to
different hardware situations
with memory hierarchies and accelerators
and networking so what's the cost
how much data are you moving what's the
cost of moving data
right and you kind of want to
like for instance in many cases you want
to be
communication avoiding
see i bet there's an analog of that in
physics
i bet there's a there's a way of or
alternatively well i mean that's a
question for for proofs for example okay
so for instance in some cases there
there are known lower bounds and
sometimes there is no algorithm yet
found that achieves the lower bound
sometimes there is one but it's to
to
uh right asymptotically too complex
doesn't doesn't actually well i would
imagine an automated theorem proving
there are issues like you know you want
to minimize the amount of memory you
need to store the intermediate
expressions for example
that would be an example of an
optimization there
but this like
i mean for for these things when you
want to find
the best in that sense i mean the
assumptions keep changing that's what
i'm saying like our hardware today is a
little bit different it was 30 years ago
um
because of the cut you know the the gap
in speeds like for compute versus
communicate communication
um
as you have to change but people often
can so the question is are optimal
algorithms even known this is like
fundamental pieces of our compute
infrastructure
sure like like linear algebras like
nothing is pretty much as fundamental
then
we still don't have optimal algorithms
right
and and there's a whole industry kind of
working on it
right
all right lots of interesting stuff
we really need to wrap this up for now
and uh
to be continued
thanks